[Applause]
yeah so i think the
biggest misunderstood part about
recovery actually starts with your
programming
okay right so it's like how much are you
how much can you recover from
based off of your lifestyle right like
you guys working nine to five guys work
in construction they all go in and do
the same
work okay you need to program
differently because stress is like an
aggregate
right stress is just stress and stress
so you got to be able to like
curate your exercise selection your
volume your intensity
to whatever other stress you have going
on right so like in a professional
athlete setting
where they can can kind of control all
their outside stressors
for the most part like you got to be
able to program
to what they can handle right so all
these modalities of like i'm gonna sit
in the sauna and all this is like
yeah but asana is not gonna out out
recover
like either under over prescribing
exercise right it's not like i'm gonna
really bury that
like drop the hammer on a workout and
then i'm gonna go sit in the sauna that
day and i'm gonna and then you're good
yeah no that's that's a bit of a that's
a bit of a myth right so i think the
most underutilized recovery tool is
actually proper exercise programming
right because you're gonna be able to
calculate and quantify the stress
more accurately that you're putting on
your body that you need to recover from
everyone's like
i'm going to go in the steam room or i'm
going to go in the sauna i'm going to
put these boots that squeeze my legs
whatever it's like i'm going to do all
this stuff i'm going to take all this
gear i'm going to take all these
supplements
and it's like well can you actually
quantify the stress that you're
accumulating in the gym first
right so it's like most people don't go
into the detail of like exercise
programming and furthermore down to the
granular detail of exercise execution
which is like how can i quantify his or
quantify his lunges that we were doing
yesterday if every rep looked
dramatically different right so like how
how can we first pre-qualify each
movement in the workout
every one of alex's reps well no
different than or isn't it like there's
a skill to it right but it's like no no
like we're all on the same level right
like and we kind of know
we're not some of us are better yeah but
it's like
even me like i've been training for 15
years this is my whole job is to break
down the granular detail and i still
have to go in and there's moves i have
to
exercise i have to practice right so
there's a skill to exercise that
pre-qualifies
quantification so everyone's like i did
four by ten at this i went for 200 pound
yolo too many circle pr on bench press
right but it's like you didn't because
winter winter solstice right
that bouncing off is a different two
hundred
pounds than if you saw your chest yeah
right so it's like
i think recovery is like what are you
recovering from and that's the biggest
thing and like that's
that's kind of the fun thing from pro
like you asked me originally like hey
why do you train us and then go trade
nfl players yeah
because it's like they're so much easy
to pro easier to program for
yeah because like the rest i know what
the rest of the day is they usually all
got twitch streams
they sit with their feet up with their
versace slides so i can kill them
because you know that they're going to
relax because i control everything
right he's going to come in you know
he'll help me up at like four in the
morning like dog i'm still not asleep
yeah but he'll he'll [ __ ] soldier in
two hours later
like on no sleep he's a dog
[Music]
and that for me is like you can program
for an athlete especially on
off season but you need to like coach
guys like you right so like programming
is very
binary like exercise programming is very
binary these guys move really well
and that's not exclusive for all pro
athletes but i can kind of write an off
season program and stick more to an off
season program with a pro athlete
because their variables are pretty well
controlled but maybe they're like if
they're in a
contract negotiation they've got to go
fly out try out for a team or something
but other than that
chilling right they make [ __ ] 22
million dollars in 17 weeks they're just
living off the interest
but it's like yo man we just got in from
phoenix last night
going through it tired so i got to be on
the fly so it's actually way more
difficult in certain ways to like coach
someone who has a more dynamic lifestyle
but pro athletes are almost like they're
very binary they're computerized like
they're robots they're
they're built to put on this planet to
do one thing and catch a football run
with football tackle a guy kick a
football
so it's like i can kind of sit back with
like all my other variables controlled
and make oh here's the here's the road
map you know we got 35 weeks in the off
season here's how we do mesocycles micro
cycles
macro cycles we put i can sit there and
just kind of abuse
versus doing crowd work we're crowd
working you don't know what the
variables are you know what's going to
happen yeah you got to read
right and then it's like yeah i've done
this a thousand times here's your
program so that's like that's the fun
thing for me and that's the proof of
concept because it's like once you get
to a certain level
like you're not like if you were just
doing netflix specials and like you were
just running
and i'm like i'm probably gonna [ __ ]
this analogy out because i don't know
your world that well
but it's like if you're just running
netflix specials and like everyone loves
you and you're not doing
you know you're not doing those like
wednesday night improv [ __ ]
you're not sharpening the muscles that's
what that is for me that's what you guys
are for me because it's like i have an
intent to the workout like i want to do
some lower body skill movement i want to
train some upper body output but some
days upper body output with akash is
going to be dumbbells because
he got four and a half hours of sleep
and for him that's a lot
he was like oh but today it's like yo
he's he's already showing me signs of
fatigue
early on in the session when we're
practicing our skill that skills
breaking down
i gotta i gotta now change my approach
but still drive the same stimulus so
rather than like a dumbbell press like
let's go to something more
external we were squatting heavy i mean
pr yeah
even with alex's real time yeah big
circles bro big sorry who's the best
natural athlete of all of us oh
oh so i mean athleticism that's a really
good question because that lettuce is
asking questions wait real quick to put
the recovery question and
and dummy terms for me right the most
important part of recovery is working
out smarter
essentially more structure okay so i
don't like that language because it's
like
you know to your nerd point earlier yeah
it's like there's a there's been a
movement for a long time and maybe like
social media was kind of driving this or
like the late night tv bowflex
[ __ ] whatever yeah but it's like
it's basically barry's bootcamp in your
living room yep but it's like they're
the intelligent movement was like this
revenge of the nerds and fitness
where everyone's like oh you got to
train smarter not harder it's like yeah
no you should probably still be laying
on the floor
right like i think when people think
about training smart
they get soft right there's a way where
it's like yeah we can know like the what
do you call it the euphrates
yeah or whatever the [ __ ] yeah yeah and
then there's your middle knee connect
to your upper dorsum yeah it's all
really complicated but it's like you can
know that
and it's still yeah it is denial
and still go there i think when people
start to train smart
they just they just don't go there
anymore yeah right so it's a
and part of it it's like putting people
in positions where they can feel safe to
go there so like we practice skills so
we did
lunges first yeah and it's like that was
a skill and like we manipulated like his
field of vision so we blocked him from
seeing his foot and we had him focus on
seeing his foot we tried to play on like
these
these ways to develop athleticism and
then after that we're like yo let's hunt
sit on a leg press grab the [ __ ]
handles breathe at this point and just
go until you can't go anywhere
right so it's like you got to be able to
play into that so to your point about
athleticism like who's the best natural
athlete
you got to define the word first who's
the best soccer player we can start
there well and that so here's my default
right because athleticism is going to
favor
more than just for pure strength right
so i would say
the most difficult sport from a
coordination standpoint
in my basketball no is
so i would give it i would give it to
him let's go boys
so athleticism is like it's you i think
you've got to try and define athleticism
first how would you guys define
athleticism
whatever i'm the best at right okay so
let's be like boxing like you're the
best boxer in the room without a doubt
yeah well right but like there are
sub components to athleticism like when
you have the goat conversation right the
greatest athlete of all time so
what does athleticism mean right so
there's so many subcomponents of
athleticism
like strength is a part of athleticism
speed agility endurance
power what about engine engine
yeah it's like being able to keep going
endurance that's a different oh
endurance right
engine
to the basics bro let me bring it back
to the basics yeah so
i mean akash brings up a point about
intangibles yeah right but i would say
like
what is intangible
[Laughter]
when you think about it we do have
intangibles
you don't think about them
yeah there's slave labor in jersey
actually depending
it's historian depending on like what
subset of athleticism you value that's
usually how people rank
their goat right like right what do you
do you value speed over power
right well then usain bolt is the best
athlete of all time
right like did you develop coor or do
you do value coordination above all else
right then you might look at some sort
of gymnast or something like you value
endurance then lance has to enter into
the conversation
right so for me especially working with
like primarily pro nfl
or pro football or nfl guys i think
there's some subsets of athleticism that
people miss
like like rhythm rhythm to me is one of
like
the most important subsets of athletics
rhythm here who got the best rhythm be
honest i haven't
realized it's not alfred you know it's
[Music]
i don't think you can necessarily like
cross-pollinate these cops can't
cross-pollinate them
there's nothing you know i think it's
not true there's nothing you all can do
i've seen these [ __ ] flippers like
scuba steve yeah that's upstairs
what does akash wear so we went barefoot
yesterday which was good oh
god no no he's coming back to the show
we did that yeah
was he hanging from the bar from his
pizza upside down
[Laughter]
with the population that i work with
primarily athleticism
comes down to rhythm like there's a
rhythm to pro football and you see it
like you ever in a college weight room
you're ever with the pros
music's blair and they're all like
dancing in between sets and then they'll
like
they'll catch balls in between a dance
move and it's like oh that's something
that we don't consider
that's something we don't consider and
it's something we should consider bro
i've been telling these [ __ ]
forever about this [ __ ]
that's one of my biggest criticisms of
fernando that's good
i look at that mother bag listen you fat
[ __ ] listen here
forget this in here
you said you would pay me 250 and make
fun of him
he would do this fernando it's all on
him it's on him i don't even know who
you are but i love you
um but but yeah man i keep on
harping on the fact that it's about
rhythm bro and he's got to get his
rhythm down
al don't have rhythm is out his nose
dancing a fashion video
that's a great point it's embarrassing
white people panted
i can't do that [ __ ] oh but like now
that's very true i always say that i got
it from him
yeah i say that all the time is the
difference between athleticism and what
we do in the gym now
when you're in a gym you're in a [ __ ]
dog house
okay and you need to come bring it bro
you need to come break come bring some
rhythm yeah
you out here doing lunges like a giraffe
that's a jordan shallow stone he said al
does lunges like a giraffe
you